معنى من عمان محمد حواري المتحدث باسم
اليونيسف في الشرق الاوسط وشمال افريقيا
سيد حواري مرحبا بك معنا كيف تقيم المنظمه
امكانيه مواكبه تداعيات زلزال تركيا
وسوريا على فئه الاطفال
هو للاسف مثل ما ذكرتم بان الطرق هي ليست
بالسهل الوصول الى المناطق المتضرره
بالاضافه الى درجات الحراره المتدنيه
والثلوج في كثير من المناطق
وقبل ان يقع هذا الزلزال كان
سابقا متفشي الكوليرا فيما بين الكثيرين
تحديدا في الشمال السوري لذلك المهمه
رئيسيه واساسيه جدا بتوفير كل ما هو ممكن
من مياه الشوربه نظيفه نحن نوفر يوميا
اليوم الماء النظيف بمعدل 300 الف لتر من
الماء في داخل حلب وفي داخل ادلب بحيث
نستطيع توفير المياه اللازم الصحي للشرب
وايضا حمايه الاطفال مما قد يواجهونه من
اوبيا لانه المرحله الصعبه تحديدا في
تقييم هذه الحاله هو تقييم كيف يمكن
حمايتهم صحيا بان لا يتعرضوا للاوبئه بعد
مثل مثل هذه الاحداث الصعبه البنيه عندما
تمس وتدمر يكون هناك الكثير من الصعوبه
للوصول المياه الصالحه للشرب حيث تختلط
المياه الصرف الصحي بالمياه الصالحه للشرب
باماكن اللواء المتضرره ولا يخفى عليكم ان
غالب السكان في تلك المناطق هم تعرضوا
لنزوح واللجوء لاكثر من مره خلال العقد
الماضي من الزمن بالتالي هم ايضا في اوضاع
صعبه ونحن كنا نناشد قبل هذا الزلزال
بمساندتهم وتوصيل المساعدات اللازمه اليوم
هناك شيء من بسيط من الامل بان التعاون
والتكاتف الدولي اصبح اكبر لكننا ما زلنا
بحاجه ماسه للتحرك والاستجابه السريعه لان
اليوم مثل ما تفضلتم هو اليوم التاسع
والثامن ما بين هذا وذاك الكثير من الاسر
ما زالت
بحاجه الى الهواء اللازم سمعنا بالكثيرين
ممن فقدوا ارواحهم بعد الانقاذ بسبب ضعف
البنيه التحتيه الصحيه في كثير من المناطق
لذلك اليوم
نحن حريصون جدا على عمل شركائنا في داخل
الارض تحديدا في داخل السوري في منطقه
ادلب هناك اكثر من 17
شريك يعمل على الارض بالاضافه الى فرقنا
للتقييم في بدايه البيان الذي ذكرناه سيد
محمد اذا اذا ما نظرنا الى الداخل السوري
هي ازمه
متراكمه ومركبه يعني تاتي مع هذا الزلزال
جهود اذا مضاعفه مطلوبه منكم الان ما هو
ترتيب اولوياتكم من اجل دعم هذه الفئه فئه
الاطفال في داخل الشمال السوري
هي متعقده هي مركبه واكثر تعقيدا خصوصا
كما نعلم جميعا ان هذه الازمه تعد الاصعب
منذ 100 عام على المنطقه منذ الحرب
العالميه الاولى فهي الاصعب الاولويه
تحديدا يجب ان نحافظ على سلامتهم الصحيه
بان لا يكون هناك تعرض للوباء لان لا
تتفشل كوليرا يجب احتواء هذا الامر بكل ما
هو ممكن هناك الكبسولات المخصصه التي تلقى
في تجمعات المائيه للتخلص من ما قد يسبب
الكوليرا واصبعها والاخرى من الامراض
الاخرى التي هي تلوثيه بسبب الاجواء
العامه بالاضافه للجو العام هناك ايضا امر
جدا مهم نحن وضعناه في قائمه الاولويات
الا وهو الدعم النفسي للمتضررين تحديدا
للاطفال للاسف وهو محزن جدا بان كثير من
الاطفال فقدوا ذويهم بالكامل سواء كان في
الجنوب التركي او في الشمال السوري
الضرر يعني ضخم جدا في البنيه الاجتماعيه
كما هو في البنيه السكانيه بالتالي نحن
بحاجه ان نضمن حق هؤلاء الاطفال بان يكون
لهم الرعايه اللازمه بان تكون هناك مراكز
حمايه اجتماعيه فاعله وقادره على الوصول
للجميع
بالرغم من كل التحديات نحن نحقق الكثير من
النجاحات بسبب التعاطف والتشارك الدولي
اليومي الذي نشهده والقرارات التي كانت
البارحة مبشره بفتح الكثير من المعابر هذا
لعله يسهل عمليه الوصول اليهم لانه قد
نخسر جيل كامل في تلك المناطق ان لم نقدم
الرعايه الطبيه اللازمه ان لم نقدم
الرعايه النفسيه الصحيحه لهم وحمايه
حقوقهم هم الاهم لانهم الاكثر تضررا لانهم
هم الحلقه الاضعف في داخل هذه الازمات مثل
ما تفضلتي في بدايه السؤال انها
ازمه مركبه ومعقده من حروب ومن نزاعات
اليوم كارثه طبيعيه شكرا جزيلا لك من عمان
محمد حواري المتحدث باسم اليونيسف في
الشرق الاوسط وشمال افريقيا